we will get started
with our final session for today
uh
my name is jay golden fine
uh thanks for
being with us and thanks for sticking
around to the end of today um before we
go and i'll just remind people we do
have more sessions tomorrow two more
sessions in the morning
um
prior to prior to lunch that both
promised to be really interesting and
fascinating so encourage you all to come
along um
we in our final session for today we
have uh andrea bobu who is a uh
here at uc berkeley andre is actually
part of
the persistent group the ai and humanity
group that has been meeting for the last
few weeks and will continue to be
meeting over the next couple of weeks
but is unfortunately traveling so i
wasn't able to be with us today but
we're very grateful that she's willing
to um offer up a presentation
uh via telepresence so
uh without further ado
um andrea
the room is yours
thank you can you all hear me we can
excellent yeah
very sad to not be there uh in person
but
i'm glad i get to at least talk to you
virtually
um so i'm gonna talk a bit today about
how robots can better generalize their
learning by aligning the representations
with the humans that they're actually
learning from
um
and let's start off by imagining that
this jayco robot arm wants to carry my
mug to the table
and so it generates a trajectory design
that optimize a optimizes a reward
function r parameterized by theta
trading off between different features
view of the task
things like the cup orientation or the
distance to the table or the efficiency
but as i watch it perform the task i'm
pretty unhappy with how high above the
table it's carrying the cup
and so what i can do is i can push on it
to correct it
let's stay closer
the robot can use my correction to
update its understanding of these
trade-offs data and the reward
and then optimize the new reward
function to adapt to how i wanted the
test to be done
now i want you to notice that the reason
this worked is that the robot already
had a representation of all of the
things that i cared about a priori like
all of these features that i mentioned
previously but that's not very realistic
real human environments are way too
complex to be able to specify every
single thing ahead of time
in fact even we as humans sometimes
don't always have the right
representation right away and children
are a great example of that so let's
look at what happens when you don't have
the right representation and this video
is going to have some audio i hope you
can all hear this
okay
does this row have more quarters does
this row have more quarters or are they
the same they say the same okay now
watch
now does this row have more quarters
does this row have more quarters or are
they the same that one has more code
that one has more quarters yeah why does
that one have more quarters because it's
stretched out now we're gonna see
another one
we're gonna take
the water from this glass
we're gonna pour it into this glass
now does this glass have more water does
this glass have more water or are they
the same
that has more water this one has more
water can you tell me why because that
one's higher than that that one's higher
than that so
here this child is clearly missing
something crucial it's
his missing the concept of conservation
of certain properties like count and
volume and that's very normal for a
child this age that doesn't develop
until uh much later a few years later
but without understanding this concept
the child was consistently making the
wrong inferences and answering uh the
researchers questions uh incorrectly and
not only that but he was also able to
explain his wrong answers with some
other concepts that he did know about
that were completely unrelated
so now let's see how this translates to
robots
this time i want the robot to stay
further away from me but the robot has
no notion of distance from people
so now my push actually makes it stay
closer to the table
so there's two crucial problems
happening here first without the right
representation the robot can't learn
what i want which is to stay further
away from me
but even worse it also tries to map my
input to something else that it does
know about this table in this case
similarly to how the child was latching
onto all those other concepts they
explained his answers
so clearly to be able to interpret
people's input correctly robots need
good human representations
but there's a question of how do we get
them
um and we're calling this question the
representation alignment problem how can
the robot align its representation in
learning with the human that it's
actually interacting with
so what we've seen so far as an answer
to this question is feature
representations that are hand specified
that are like written down by a system
designer a priori on top of which the
robot learns a reward function from the
human input ah theta so we just saw
corrections as does input but there's
many other types of them but like
demonstrations tele operation and so on
and then it optimizes that reward to
produce trajectories in the world
and the problem is that this does
require this uh a priori specification
that is not very viable
so there's a simple solution to this you
might say you can just learn the
features as well after all that's the
main thing that the deep learning
revolution has enabled us to do and
let's try that and see what happens in
practice
so i'm going to show you this example
where the person cares about being
efficient and keeping the cup close to
the table that we just saw and away from
a laptop on the table
so if we imagine the table is the ground
plane spatially the human's reward might
look something like this
where the lowest reward in yellow is
right above the laptop and high from the
table above the table and it gets better
the closer to the table and the farther
from the laptop we look
meanwhile the robot knows about some of
these features but not about distances
to laptops so what we want this for the
robot to somehow learn about this
missing feature and how it combines with
the remaining features of the reward
function
so deep learning tells us that we can
actually do both of these things at once
first you model the missing features in
your network and you add it to your set
of known features
you collect a few demonstrations of the
task from the human and use them to both
extract what's missing implicitly and
learn the reward function r theta on top
of that
it turns out that when you actually do
this uh we fatally learned that being
around the laptop is bad but we don't
really learn the more fine-grained
details of the reward function
and that's because the demonstrations
that the person gives are only meant to
teach the robot how to do the task they
aren't meant for learning the features
per se
so the method is just sort of hoping to
capture that information the missing
features implicitly through the
demonstrations
but doing that effectively requires
thousands of demonstrations which we
simply just don't have in human robot
interaction scenarios
so by trying to both extract salient
features of the task and the reward on
top of them all at once for with just a
few demonstrations deep learning
generalizes pretty poorly
and the implication is that
now when we optimize the reward we see a
behavior that
mostly stays away from the laptop it
doesn't really go close to the table as
i would actually do if i were to do the
task
so what we have is one method that lets
the robot learn a reward by specifying
the representation but specifying the
representation is difficult and then
another method that avoids that but does
a poor job extracting both the
representation and the reward implicitly
from little data so the question is can
we somehow get the best of both worlds
here
and the core idea that i'm going to be
presenting is this idea of dividing and
conquering the robot learning problem
let's first focus explicitly on learning
the representation from human input so
that's the orange part
before using it for the downstream
reward learning problem
and what this means here is that we
can't just rely on input design to teach
you the representation implicitly like
the demonstrations that we just saw
earlier and instead we need to actually
design special human input ahv that is
explicitly targeted at teaching you
about the representation about the
features
and it can do so effectively and this
part is the one that i'm going to focus
on for the rest of the talk
so coming back to this example where we
had the deep inverse reinforcement
learning or irl method that try to learn
both the representation of the word at
once
from the high dimensional raw state of
the robot
um
what if instead we apply this divide and
conquer philosophy and first focused on
learning the feature
by asking the human first some sort of
input about it i'm going to tell you in
a second and only then learn the reward
from
reward inputs like demonstrations or the
corrections that we saw earlier
so now there's a question of okay andrea
but how do you learn these features well
we can still model a feature as a neural
network
and one naive solution would be to ask
them for
different labels representing the
feature value of certain states and then
use these labels to train the network
via supervised learning
the problem is that to learn anything
useful the robot will need a very large
set of labels from the person and
that's way too burdensome to to collect
to ask a person to do
and even worse the
humans can actually be pretty imprecise
at labeling states directly with like
real numbers
and so what we need here is some sort of
feature input that
trades off being informative and at the
same time not placing too much burden
too much sample complexity burn on the
human that's giving that input
so our idea here was that instead of
having the person label states
independently
we can pack a lot more information if we
ask the person for a sequence of states
with feature values that are
monotonically decreasing along the trace
and we call the sequence
a sequence with this property of feature
traits
and in practice what this looks like is
that if i want to teach the robot about
distance from the laptop i start
somewhere where the feature is highly
expressed so right above the laptop and
then move it monotonically towards a
place where it's not highly expressed so
away from the laptop
the robot collects a few of these traces
and then it can learn a future function
that is defined by them
the beauty in these future traits is
that
there's a lot of inherent structure
packed into them and we can hard
actually train in your network
efficiently so first we have the feature
traces monetization assumption where the
future values decrease along the states
of the trace
but next we also know that all of the
traces approximately start at a high
feature value and then a low on so for
two traces what this means is that the
starts the labels for the starts have to
be consistently high and the labels for
the ends have to be consistently low
and lastly humans are imperfect so we
modeled them as noisily rational
according to the bradley terry and lewis
shepard model
so now we can't learn from the feature
traces directly we need but what we can
do is we can transform them into a data
set of tuples that are actually suitable
for look for training
so the way we do that is from we take
each of these properties and transform
them into tuples from the first
uh assumption the monotony assumption we
can take any ordered combination of two
states along the trace and label them a
one which means that the first state in
the tuple has a higher future value than
the second
and what's special about this is that
for each trace we get a number of tuples
that's quadratic in the length of the
trace which is a lot of data it's a lot
of comparisons
now for the second assumption we
essentially want all of the starts to be
indistinguishable from one another and
all the ends to be indistinguishable
from one another and that gives us
equivalence to post with a label of zero
five to symbolize the fact that these
two states in the tuple are equivalent
and lastly we incorporate this
noisy assumption into a cross-entropy
loss
for trading a simple multi-layer
perceptron network using these
tuples
and i want to show you some actual
examples of features that we learned
using feature traces from both expert
users with a physical robot aka me
and as well
as with non-expert users in simulation
um this happened in simulation because
this was happening during like the
depths of coven in 2020
um so like we can exactly do this
experiment with real people
unfortunately
and for both qualitative and
quantitative evaluation here i'm gonna
show you these sampled uh test set of
states across the robot's reachable set
so this is the 3d ball of points that
i'm showing you here
and what i'm visualizing here with
colors is the feature values and all of
these points and in yellow you have a
high feature value because the robot is
closer to the laptop and then it gets
more to the blue as you go farther away
from the laptop and for easier
visualization we can also project the
feature ball onto a representative plane
like here
so let's first look at results with
expert data that are for me indicated by
this icon in the top right when we look
at the ground truth laptop feature we
see a projected ball that decreases in
intensity the farther from the laptop we
look
and then with our method
we're able to learn a structurally very
similar feature which is really cool and
this actually um is stays true for all
of the other features we look at some
stuff like business to the table
proxemics
coffee cup orientation and so on
um and
keep in mind that this result
um these results i'm showing you here
are collected with like 10 or 20 feature
traces not thousands so this is much
more manageable for a person to give
and quantitatively um we essentially
looked at the learned feature valued 3d
bulbs and compared them to the ground
truth feature values and um just
computed the mean square there between
them so here lower is better what we see
is that with enough data our method
learns features that are much better
than random random is that dotted line
in gray
and then with more data it becomes um
the features that we're learning become
increasingly better and our method also
gets less input sensitive as we see by
this decreasing standard there and
overall these three observations tell us
that we can learn good features with
expert feature traces but what about
novice users
um we were it turns out that we were
also actually able to learn good
features
here
the user
data is in yellow and when compared to
the
they are closer in performance to the
orange which is the expert level than to
the gray which is the random performance
that tells us that even with novice data
you're able to learn um something that
has some structure
okay so now that we've seen how to learn
features
uh let's look at how we can use this
pipeline to learn uh the reward and
we're going to compare that against the
deep learning baseline from the
beginning now i looked at two settings
first there's the online learning one
where the robot starts off with some
features already it detects that it's
missing something and it expands its
representation with a new feature that
we learned the way i just showed you and
then we combined them all into the
reward function
and so we took furl uh future expansive
reward learning which is what our method
is called um which first learns the
feature from traces and then the rewards
from corrections and we compared it
against maximum entropy rl which learns
both from demonstrations
and for the setting the human cared
about two features and the
representation for the reward one of
which was unknown to the robot and we
varied which of the laptop
uh table and proximix feature was
unknown
and in these visualizations what we see
is consistently pearl is able to learn a
fine grain a more fine grained reward
structure than
max and irl
and this result is also
confirmed quantitatively as well
and we also took the user thought so the
novice thought features and performed
reward learning and we kind of see the
same story where yellow is closer to
orange than um to the uh deep the
baseline and gray
even though the max and thyroid baseline
used expert demonstrations
and they
that were performed on the physical
robots and not in simulation so even
though our method was a disadvantage it
still performs better because the
structure that features in these is so
useful
we also looked at an offline setting
where this time the robot knows nothing
a priori no features and it just needs
to learn each one of them one at a time
and then learn the reward on top
and so we compared furl here which again
learns each feature one at a time and
then learns the rewards with
demonstrations against the max and
parallel baseline
and this time we had three scenarios
with where the reward depended on one
two or three features and the robot
stores completely from scratch
and when we look at the results
what we see is that for the single
feature case up top
which is a simpler reward structure both
methods actually perform well but for
the other two structures which are more
complicated and
maybe have more detail to them furl is
qualitatively much closer to the ground
truth than um max entirel the deep deep
variant
and these results are also confirmed
quantitatively
and now when we're looking at the same
experiments with non-expert features the
the results are a bit more mixed so what
we see here is that yellow which is the
non-expert features
it's not necessarily providing a
reliable advantage when compared to max
entirely
and we think this might be the case
because again people did teach these
features in a simulator whereas max
entirel still operates with real
physical expert demonstrations so when
you like add a bunch of
little noisier features together maybe
you don't necessarily get as much of the
structure benefit as uh you get with
expert uh features as you see with
orange
but overall
i'm very excited about our progress so
far and um i really hope that this
divide and conquer philosophy can result
in more generalizable reward robot
learning perhaps even extending domains
outside of reward learning as well
thank you
okay uh thanks so much for that
presentation i'm really
uh
i'm really interested in this idea of
like the noisy human because so much of
what we've been doing seems to be trying
to figure out exactly what it is
a human means or a human wants or what
human values
or what
a human is capable of of doing in all
different kinds of contexts so i
appreciate this this thing that's
connecting what we've been talking about
does anyone have uh questions for andre
yeah uh sonya anyone else
at this stage okay
keep thinking
this is super interesting thank you so
um i'm really curious so you mentioned
that one of the factors was
how high the robot arm is off the table
now what what struck me about this and
watching the robot
perform was that it seemed like well why
do the humans care if the arm is so high
i mean maybe the robot's teaching us
something that maybe it's kind of
superfluous because that seemed to be a
preference you threw in there that i
didn't i mean i got the laptop that
seemed to make a lot of sense but maybe
the robot had something there that we
should learn from like why why that idea
that that arm should be higher is just
an arbitrary addition
i see yeah um i guess the full story of
that was that if the robot is carrying
um
like your precious mug or maybe it's
carrying some some liquid in that mug
i guess it being closer to the table
means that it risks
spilling all over the place a little
less or if it drops by accident the mug
it's not gonna shatter
on the table because it's going to be
closer to the table but it's it's true
that in like
in general these
examples are um
like we can't we can't incept
preferences in the people's heads
so
as part of the experiments you can't
kind of have to
uh but as part of the experiments you do
have to somehow make people comparable
which is really hard um and so because
of that you kind of have to give them a
script and be like i imagine that
um you don't want this cup to
to be spilling liquid close to the the
laptop imagine that you don't want the
robot to accidentally spill uh
sorry the
robot to accidentally um let go of the
cup and shatter the cup and so on um so
yeah we do kind of create these
scenarios when we
run our users
studies
so because it seems like that there's
this i don't know if it's trade-off is
the right word but the way so the laptop
and trying to get the computer to
conceptualize
that you shouldn't hover over the laptop
with the liquid that it is interesting
to try to think about what is implicit
and explicit in the way we maneuver in
our environments and i guess that's
what's tricky about this and this is
because because with the robotic arm
height i mean you can think about that
maybe for i mean intuitively it seems
like of course you don't want accidents
to happen or the cup to slip but what if
it's a case where i know there's some
treachery that you should be a certain
uh you know elevated a certain amount
above the table so i guess i found
myself trying to figure out how
even in setting up the experiment trying
to figure out the implicit versus the
explicit it seems like a really tricky
space to be functioning yeah
i think i think you're asking a question
of
maybe like something that's not captured
here at all is the communication of
like
right now a lot of a lot of this work is
a human tells robots what to do but
there's no communication of like robot
tells human what it knows or why it's
trying to do what it's doing so i think
um this is not something i've explored
yet but i'm actually really excited uh
about in the future um once i i have
this idea that once you have once these
uh representations are aligned you're
basically you should in principle uh be
able to open the communication channels
both ways both from human to teach the
robot more efficiently and also for the
robot to explain to the human what it
knows and what it doesn't know more
efficiently and more more interpretable
interpretably um if you so wish
so that's that's an aspect this this
aspect of explainability and maybe
interpretability is something that i'm
really excited to
explore in the future
thank you
um i guess i have a question
um
so we this morning uh you know and i
imagine you weren't don't have the
advantage of seeing the some of the
papers that we heard this morning but um
smither and sarah were both uh
describing certain projects in
recommender systems
they were effectively about
trying to map
an abstract form of value
uh from the human via
uh like
looking at you know behavioral signals
with respect to how they interact with
content or some sort of recommendation
system
is this kind is is is
is working for it towards a reward
function or trying to determine the
reward effectively the same thing but in
an embodied space
yes
yeah i would i think that i didn't see
the talk but i would i would think that
that is the case yes
and and i suppose the question becomes
then um is there you know
besides kind of the obvious is there uh
what are the differences or what do you
imagine the differences might be
in trying to map
unarticulated
behave like cognitive preferences versus
unarticulated human know-how with
respect to doing something in the world
sorry um
unarticulated cognitive preferences well
so
yeah so so the recommender system one is
like humans aren't saying exactly what
they want with respect to the content
that they like
they're just doing something and we're
trying to effectively read their minds
and then when the stuff you're doing is
about you know embodied know-how how how
we do stuff in the world that we don't
necessarily articulate uh we don't say
to the robot you know like when you move
a cup these are all the things that uh
our bodies just know what to do
implicitly because we've learnt them
from convention and repeating in action
so many times so
i'm just asking you to maybe speculate a
little bit about you know what's the
i guess
i guess it's a philosophical question
what's like what what might be the
differences between those two kinds of
of processes of trying to understand
what a human
can do and what they're about
yeah so
if i understand correctly the first
scenario is
um
maybe a recommender system scenario
where
the
ai
sort of watches your behavior
and then learns what you like just by
passively watching your behavior
and the second scenario the one that
i've been talking about is one where the
human actively takes on the role of a
teacher so the human is trying to like
is very conscious that they are uh
trying to teach the robot something so
in that sense the data is different
um
the way you communicate it is different
the kinds of rewards that you're gonna
learn are very different
the
issues
i think both votes
maybe the second one will have the issue
of
um i might try to specify to like teach
you what the reward is but i might
myself be wrong about this reward i
might give you examples of the flights
that i prefer for example and tell you
look i like
this flight from
x to y that
cost a lot of money and i like this
flight from
y to z that also costs a lot of money
and then you're gonna learn that okay
andrea likes uh to take expensive
flights but in reality the reason they
cost a lot of money is that they were
all they were both uh non-stop and so if
you had seen more data of me choosing
um
choosing flights that were cheaper uh
and none and non-stop then maybe you
will have drawn you would have drawn
different inferences but there is this
risk of when i'm teaching you stuff
myself you might draw the wrong
inferences because i'm not giving you
enough data or diverse enough data
and because i myself am not thinking of
all the possible scenarios that could
pos could exist out there in the world
so that's so i guess
there is this risk of uh learning the
wrong reward or maybe
um
maybe
learning how to exploit the system
in order to score
what what the robot thinks is high
reward but is not actually the what the
person wanted in in the first place
yeah thanks thanks for that that's
really helpful and i suppose it
maybe raises a question for the ethicist
here which is whether what whether
there's a
a really meaningful distinction between
the way that a human
value or human reward is modeled in
their
um didactic interaction with a with an
electronic system a computational system
versus one that's kind of almost trying
to trick them into
revealing their preferences like a game
theory model that we heard before um
helen
yeah it's
i thought
jake your question was um
i left the question because i hadn't
seen that these discussions we we've
been having with smither about
um what's
the they're the different vectors let's
say
in input one is behavioral i mean
they're lots but
uh one class of them are behavioral and
the other are like just ask the person
what they like you know get get that
input so
i hadn't
seen
the connection between
that and in this kind of work that
andrea is doing
and when i was listening andrea to you
saying
you know if i don't give them enough
information they might think
you know the
system might uh infer that
i like expensive flights and then i'm i
i was
i was going to a different conclusion
which was
well just ask the person is it that you
like expensive lights or you like
non-stop lights like why go through this
whole behavioral observation yeah but
the question i wanted the actual
question i wanted to ask you
was i i'm also very happy with the way
you prefaced the presentation because it
feels like
we've been having some impact
on on your thinking
and so just one little
thought from you about
okay the coffee cup case
we can get on board with because maybe
there's a sense of agreement about what
we want we don't want our coffee to
spill on our computers so good good on
you that you're
teaching that to the
robot arm but
how do you
see
moving into more dangerous territory
when you're making assumption about
human need or human preference
as the reinforcement learning
designer
and you you would say to yourself i have
to now be a little bit more cautious
about this
[Music]
um
yeah so
let me let me see if i understand the
question by giving an example
suppose that my cup is filled with water
and i'm trying to teach you
the
like cup orientation um feature so what
i would normally do is i would start
where the cup is up right and then take
you completely like
180 degrees like like basically flipped
um the problem is that if i do that with
a cup that has water in it i'm going to
spill all the water or coffee or
whatever so are you asking
how do you teach stuff like this
when
actually giving the input is a little
dangerous or is not
it's not it's not safe
it was more about
teaching a task
where they don't think she could
my question was moving away from that
that that case is terrific also but it
was more about moving away from the
robot
almond and coffee
and and a slightly more complex maybe
complex
complicating it but the fact that we
don't actually know that all humans
share a lot of or maybe some subsection
of humans
gender their gender differences and so
forth but you as the designer have to
as sts scholars might say inscribe the
user
when you're
teaching through reinforcement learning
so maybe you're talking about
personalization
um so these rewards right now the way i
presented them they're kind of meant to
work for
just the the average human
but not every human is the average human
and so how do you personalize these to
like each individual person
and
um that's a good question
i think
part of the difficulty right now and a
lot of work out there
is that so a lot of work in reward
learning and just robot learning in
general kind of assumes that
you have a system designer or a sort of
expert that is able to collect data to
give to the robot
um but the problem is that not everyone
is the system designer not everyone has
the same
you know beliefs or preferences or
whatever as system designers so how so
ideally you would like the like each
individual person
to
give input on their own as well and the
problem is that a lot of the
types of input that exist right now
are not necessarily suitable for
novice
users like
people nor regular people don't know how
to program
a robot um they don't know how to give
this very specific type of input to
teach them about how to do stuff um and
there's the danger that
if they don't know how to do how to
program the robot they might do it
incorrectly um they might teach you the
wrong thing and or they might not teach
it anything at all
so i think i believe that a really
important direction would be to come up
with interfaces come up with types of
input that are just much easier for
regular people to to give and i think we
should start focusing on efforts on the
regular
person uh and on like trying to
personalize these things to
actual end users and not just assume
that each person is going to be some
kind of oracle that gives you uh the
perfect data
or each person is going to be the
average human that's going to give you
that like just average human data
um
this is probably more of a comment but
it's it's just reflecting on the
conversation as it's gone and it just
it's just making me think of this kind
of um
sort of etymological and philosophical
lineage that gets a bit obscured in the
english word technology
so the distinction between a kind of
embodied technique or artisanal
knowledge or just the ways in which
humans
behave and the way that we make things
and interact with the world
versus
the kind so that being like technique or
techne versus its abstraction as
technology like the kind of epistemic
superiority of like you know when we
convert that into an abstraction and
turn it into a sort of scientific
project and then produce a sort of
factory that replaces the artisanal
workers the kind of classic distinction
and
there's a lot of critical scholarship
that sort of is centered on
um kind of defending the kind of moral
worth of techniques themselves as they
are embodied and learned and passed
along
and it's interesting in this example i
just think because there's a kind of
doubling going on where andrea like
you're working in is in itself a kind of
process of learning how to how to
capture technique and abstract them into
a kind of robot behavior
um which which creates an interesting
sort of potentially an involuted loop
between what humans are doing and how
how they will interact with the robots
that have been
designed in a kind of technology
technologization of human behavior this
is just an observation but
um it it's maybe the distinction that i
think helen was just getting out that's
how i kind of see that that kind of
distinction
seems real
i see
hi andrea i had a
question about this sort of
the process of the machine learning that
you're talking about the robotic
learning
whether or not you followed up on any i
think there was some work done at
university of georgia georgia tech where
they took the sort of human ontology
model
about how small children you had the
toddler in your your video
and how children learn to do things and
how they learn concepts
and one of the things that's built into
their thinking was robots need to learn
to do things with humans
the way humans learn to do things with
humans that's by interacting with them
over a period of time
but one thing that happens for those of
us who have the great pleasure of
raising children is when your kids get
to the phase when they all start going
why
why are you doing that why do you say
that why
and so asking for like a causal
explanation like so that the child as i
see is going through some causal mapping
using andy clark's terms
in an embodied sense they're trying to
figure out causally where should i
situate myself vis-a-vis this person mom
or dad that i'm interacting with i'm
just wondering whether
that could be sort of
modeled into the process you're talking
about to get a more embodied
interactive
sort of questioning like we've been
talking earlier this morning about ai
being explainable to humans
but you're actually wanting humans to be
explainable to the machine
so the robot gets an explanation as to
why it should lower the cup rather than
taking over the high root as sonia said
it just wants to know why it does it's
not resistant but it does want to know
why and so part of that process of
learning somehow building that into the
system
[Music]
yeah i love that question
um
i guess uh
in the depths of my research i've been
thinking of these features as a as a why
um
because
i mean i know it's it's not necessarily
super obvious but i'm thinking
um the typical reward input is a
demonstration i show you how to do the
task
but then the y's are kind of the
features of this trajectory that i'm
showing you um there's the y of the
distance to the table or there's the y
of the distance to the laptop so i guess
there's this
communication through just like the
computerized values that these features
have
but i think ideally in the future i
would love for this communication to
happen through natural language so
right now the feature distance the table
is just like feature number one or
feature number two the robot doesn't
really know
what they mean in terms of language so i
think language is going to be super
powerful because
um if the human could tell it
um
like
it's super powerful because you have
this
shared way of communicating where the
human can tell you um it's because
i want you to be closer to the table and
then the robot can translate that and be
like ah okay the distance to the table
feature has to be you want me to keep
that lower in general that got it great
i understand that
um
so
i think
in essence at all of these all of these
types of inputs even with that
correction with the push that's in what
i'm trying to communicate the robot i'm
trying to communicate stay closer to the
table but i'm doing so indirectly i'm
just
like
pushing you to do that and you're just
kind of learning that oh you want me to
stay closer to the
table but they don't ever get an
explicit communication
because you're doing the task wrong
because i want you to stay closer to the
table and i think um
yeah i think language is going to be
super important for that
thank you so much uh let's uh say thanks
to andrea for the talk
[Applause]
thank you for having me
i hope you'll enjoy the
[Music]
the
banquet or whatever is happening after
this
total pleasure okay so we have just like
a few minutes before uh
while they're finalizing the setup for
uh the reception and i suppose we can
use the time to do like
you know
customer feedback survey or maybe some
some form of taking stock of what's
happened if anyone has um
thoughts that they might want to express
to the group uh around
you know
what what we're doing here
what what we might
continue to do or could do better or
what sorts of things we might be
interested in
in producing out of this or how could
some of this you know like really quite
radically experimentally
interdisciplinary um
sort of thinking
like be meaningful
to
to others
so you know this is open to to anyone to
reflect on and to comment on i do
realize it's the end of the day and
we're all a bit tired but maybe it's
also just a chance to take those
questions on board and maybe think about
them over a little while
yeah i mean this is more you have a flag
for tomorrow than something to do now
but i'd love to just have some space
separate from the particular panels just
to have sort of free-form conversation
of where do we take this next doesn't
you know it doesn't have to be like
here's the paper we're all going to
write but what are some open areas for
continuing dialogue and finding
collaborations or research funding or
just thinking about what a research
agenda around these topics looks like
because i think sort of to try to just
find ways to synthesize the conversation
and think about paths forward however
loose or precise we want to be around
that
yeah i think that's um
that that's what hike means
in the schedule
one way or another
maybe hopefully hope like i always heard
imagine that if we are going for a walk
outside together then maybe
that's the kind of thing that we might
be trying to
to generate a whiteboard
one you could wear a whiteboard as a
backpack and then someone will bring
sharpies you have a nice white shirt
where you can just use your back fine by
me
i do think that
um